of
that.
[Silence]
Roughly
one
roughly
four of the
[Silence]
medium hand
basket.
[Silence]
and a half to three kilos. It's an
approximation and alhamdulillah it is an
approximation because exact measurements
especially when it comes to volume and
weight in Islamic law are usually
overlooked. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
he says subhanahua
I'm glitching a little bit. He says,
"Subhan,
[Silence]
so he says, "And if you measure or
weigh, then be
correct and be truthful and
dutiful
and be precise as possible. Then he
says,
"Allah holds no soul to account more
than it can bear." The scholars take
from this the approximation that takes
place with respect to weights and
volume. It's almost impossible to be
perfectly exact. And so a lot of the
measurements in the sunnah are an
approximation.
Today inshallah we want to discuss some
of the etiquets of fasting. Now the
author takes us into a chapter which
complements the previous chapter. The
previous chapter spoke about the bare
minimum of fasting. what is absolutely
necessary and what will compromise a
person's fast. Right? This chapter is
going to discuss what betters a person's
fast and what is appropriate and what is
inappropriate for a person who is
fasting.
He says it is preferred.
Preferred.
Preference
is a ruling in Islam.
And preference
has
has an approximation
or preference has parameters to it. And
these terms are used by the scholars of
the jurists of Islam to refer to that
which is preferred.
It is not obligatory.
It is commanded
but commanded without obligation. And
this is an important point.
[Silence]
and so that which is that which is
preferred,
it is a command of Allah. When we say
this is preferred,
this is optional, this is highly
highly encouraged. It means that
Allah commanded it. He commanded that we
do it. But he commanded that we do it
without obligation.
So what is the ruling with respect to
that which is the ruling
is that those who do it
are rewarded,
but those who fail to do it are not held
to account.
But those who fail to do it are not held
to account. But they are commands.
The first of these etiquets, the most
important of these etiquets with respect
to fasting is
breakfast
is breakfast
and that is that it is referred to as
why is it referred to as in the Arabic
language?
These three letters when they come
together they articulate something that
is hidden.
That's why we refer to magic as what
right it has the same origins as
because magic you see a result but you
don't know the how. Right? This is the
idea. the exact how is hidden.
And so auror
is breakfast, but it's not just
breakfast at any time. It's breakfast in
the darkest part of the night before
dawn. That's why it's referred to as
sahur because it's it's dark. It's
usually hidden, right? People are doing
it in their homes. It's not something
very public, very prominent. And so it's
referred to as the Arabs refer to a
pre-dawn breakfast asur.
And so a sour is highly encouraged. As a
matter of fact, it is so highly
encouraged that some of the scholars of
Islam have viewed a to be obligatory.
Now the majority of the scholarship of
Islam
hold aur to be highly encouraged.
However, this is to show you the amount
of emphasis that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam put on to the point that some
scholars
concluded from the evidence that it
is obligatory and that it is a part of
fasting.
Is mentioned in the Quran?
A little trivia.
I can't see. You're you're sitting
behind a thing. You should sit a little
further. As a matter of fact, go outside
and listen through the window.
What is it?
Is it mentioned in the Quran?
[Arabic recitation]
It's not eating,
meaning they make
during the late hours
pre-dawn. Okay, very good. You got
one word, but there's actually two
eating.
There we go. We have our own our very
own homegrown
here. Mashallah. Allah says,
Some of the mufire have understood this
to be a
and eat and proceed to eat and drink
until
the th the white thread of dawn
distinguishes itself from the black
thread of night. And then begin your
fast until nightfall. And we said
nightfall in Islam is when when is
nightfall
when when is
when the disc of the sun sets under the
horizon. This is even if it's very
bright out. It is considered to be
night. This is nightfall.
He says,
"What is anis's
abdman?"
That's the default ka, isn't it? Abu
Abdullah and Abu Abdman. Just shoot that
one. You might as No, it's not Abu
Abdman. Nor is it Abu Abdullah.
Huh?
Well, that's his father's name. Yes.
Anisb Malik. But his Abu
Abu Hamza Abu Hamza
anis how long h how old was he when he
passed away?
Over 120. Yes. Very good. Very good. Abu
Abu Hamza Anison.
If we were to say
with on the scene, it is the act of
breakfast. If we say
it is what you eat for breakfast, right?
So,
eating breakfast. So,
is what you eat. It's the actual food
that's with a fat on the scene. If we
put a on the scene, it's the breakfast
itself. It's it's the act of eating
breakfast. Our prophet Sam
tells us as reported by Bkari a Muslim.
He says,
"Have
eat
for indeed there is great blessing in
bar."
What is alaka
in the Arabic language? What's it mean?
Baraka.
Blessings. That's what we usually
translate it as, right?
But when we look at the etmology of the
word,
it comes when we look at
these three letters in this order in the
Arabic language articulate an immense
wealth of good.
That's why we call a pond or a lake,
what do we call it in Arabic? B
because it is a a wealth of remnant good
is not just good or a lot of it. It has
three things good and it's a lot immense
and it is permanent.
It is continuous.
So we call a a lake a ba because it is a
wealth of permanent remnant good.
Likewise a camel when a camel lays down
what do we call this bur or bak right
the camels I mean that is the most
valuable thing in the to the Arabs
camels
and water
right could you think of anything more
important if you're living in the middle
of the desert than a camel and water so
that's why they use these letters s to
describe the camel, to describe water
and to describe blessings. One of the
names of Allah
is
that he subhanahu wa'ta'ala or one of
his descriptions we hear often in the
Quran
right meaning blessed
is he subhanahu wa ta'ala our prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam tells us eat
that prefasting pre-dawn breakfast
for indeed there is an immense wealth of
remnant good. There is great blessing in
aur
not only from a physical standpoint but
also from a
hasset standpoint. A person when
they're eating breakfast for the purpose
of fasting they're being rewarded.
They're being rewarded for every bite.
They are in an act of worship when they
are eating that.
He says,
"So what are what is the bare minimum
of?" Let's quantify it.
He said, "And a person would be
considered to have had
even if they swallow one gulp of water."
Just swallow one gulp of water. This is
considered to be the person has done.
This is the bare minimum of
[Silence]
collected in his authentic compilation
on the authority of Abdullahb
al may Allah be pleased with him and his
father both our companion companions. He
said the messenger of Allah
said have
that pre-dawn breakfast. Take
even if only one gulp of water. So by
this statement
the bare minimum of a is at least one
drink of water.
and making a as close to the break of
dawn as possible. This is something
which as well is highly encouraged by
our prophet sallall.aii wasallam. He
says anis
what is anis's
abs.
Okay, look at that. We have a historian
here too. Mashallah.
[Silence]
Bkari Muslim. We'll end with this
narration.
The clock is kicking me out. in Bkari
Muslim
Malik narrates that
said now we have a companion narrating
from a companion but
is a more senior companion than anis
zabit is one of the major reciters of
the Quran he's one of the major
and he's also one of the scribes of the
prophet Sallallah.aii wasallam which is
a a very very high station. This is a
station of immense
esteem to be the prophet's scribe for
the Quran. So Annis who is a minor
companion compared to Zet who is a more
or more senior companion. Annus asks
Zinab and narrates that Zinab told them.
He said, "We had a with the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and then he got up
and made salah." Which salah is this?
So we understand from that that was how
close to very close for him to have
breakfast and then get up to make salah.
This means they were very very close
right up to the last minute. And so
Annis asked Zade, he said, "How much
time was there between
and then for?"
He said
about 50 verses.
About 50 verses.
We could quantify that to be roughly 10
minutes roughly because the verses are
not very long verses nor are they very
short verses. Medium verses recited in a
moderate pace. This is 50 verses.
So it's roughly 10 minutes. So there was
roughly 10 minutes 10 to 12 minutes
between his
and his salah or the and tomorrow
inshallah we will speak about the topic
of when ends absolutely ends and when I
absolutely begins
[Arabic recitation]